two months on from Chris kappa's death
the campaign in his name continues
which are a slightly different one today
with a vigil taking place before a
climate protest
but the chorus calling for justice still
the same campaigners supporting the
family say they will stand with other
groups to keep the case in the spotlight
one of the tools that we definitely used
around
Chris Carver campaign was the unity from
all sectors from all works of life from
all organizations like this
unity and saying how do we amplify our
voice by standing unified together this
is the fourth March or demonstration
calling for justice for Chris Cabot in
two months but as you can see it looks
and feels slightly different that's
because this vigil is part of a climate
March a reminder of how different groups
are coalescing around the family's
campaign for justice
that campaign has seen as parents
protest while grieving their sadness and
their stoicism on show at a recent March
that day they delivered a letter to the
Prime Minister alongside other families
who had lost loved ones in similar
circumstances
their words afterwards a reminder they
are still seeking answers
said how was the death of Chris
the word of kiss the last minute what
Chrissy said I want them to answer me
for both of you how hopeful are you that
Chris's Legacy can be changed
I need it as soon as possible they need
to take it as an energy
urgent problem Chris Kappa was shot and
killed by an officer in streatham South
London on September 5th the independent
office for police conduct have set a six
to nine month time scale for looking
into the incident it said it understands
that people want answers quickly but
this is a complex investigation
involving a significant amount of
evidence
while the wait for more information
continues people will keep Gathering and
trying to give this campaign a voice
shinky marike Sky News